hi everyone this is jeremy shifling of
khan academy i'm joined by our amazing
leader of professional learning uh megan
patani and megan has a real treat in
store for you today because she's going
to walk you through not the educator
experience that you're used to on the
site but the student experience so you
can see exactly what your students are
seeing and deliver them an awesome
experience with all the remote learning
challenges we all have at this moment
so that being said
megan is going to start to share with
you
what it looks like through the lens of a
student using khan academy and then in
true webinar fashion if you have any
questions whatsoever you can ask those
at any time using the questions feature
and we'll take those both throughout and
then also at the end so that being said
thank you so much for joining us today
i'll turn it over to megan
thanks so much jeremy
so we're going to jump right in and just
a quick note of what we will and will
not cover today so we're going to cover
the student experience and i know a lot
of teachers and parents have a lot of
questions about this and we're going to
walk through the student experience on
khan academy to help you as parents or
teachers better understand what your
students and or children are learning
but we will not cover today the teacher
and parent experiences we have some of
the resources about the parent and
teacher experience and if you'd like to
take a look at those
definitely reach out to our keep
learning site uh keep learning at khan
academy.org
and there you'll have more information
about parent and teacher experiences so
that being said
i'm gonna jump right into our live
product
and so here's how we're going to start
so once students log into khan academy
so if they have an existing account
either a personal account or one they
have through their school or district
they log in here if they need to create
an account
they can do that pretty easily they can
use that same google login they might
have for school or if they are under 13
you as a parent can help walk them
through that process and once they're
logged in they're going to land here
this is what we call our learner home
and you might be asking yourself well
who is a learner will be a khan academy
view everyone as a learner and
especially our students and so this is
where they're going to find
everything else they need to access on
khan academy
and one trick we always like to share
with our students and teachers is that
anywhere you are on the khan academy
site by clicking that khan academy logo
at the top they'll return right back to
this learner home
and so on this page you'll see a whole
bunch of things and we're going to start
at the top and then we'll work through
the rest
so on the left hand side here you'll see
this little avatar which students can
update and you'll see their name
and their username and an option here to
add their bio by clicking on this
students can edit this information and
just one thing i always like to call out
to parents and to teachers is this basic
information the username the avatar and
the bio information that students share
is publicly available so
just to be a little bit cautious about
what they put there
when they land on the learner home
they'll see if their teacher has
assigned them course mastery or
assignments they'll see those broken
down by class on the left hand side and
so you can see on my student account
here that in my period one algebra one
class i have a course mastery goal that
you see here and then i also have
assignments from my teacher so anything
they need from an individual class will
be there on the left hand side
if they have courses that they'd like to
study on their own
under this next category of information
where it says my stuff
students will see courses and these are
courses that the student has selected
themselves to study and when students
sign up for an account they'll have the
opportunity to pick which courses they'd
like to study on their own and we
recommend things that they might be
studying in school or things that just
interest them and so they can always
edit those courses by clicking the blue
button at the top
below this i also want to call out this
sat button
for students that might be in the high
school age they have the opportunity to
link their college board account with
their khan academy account and so they
can import existing psat or sat scores
and get personalized recommendation
across math reading and writing and
essays
and so if students want to do that or if
they haven't taken it yet we also offer
diagnostics if they add s-a-t again when
they set up their account they have a
button that offers them to add sat as a
course they'll be added this sat tab and
they can practice
recommended exercises fit to their
personalized results
if you scroll down a little bit further
in the my account area
one other thing i'd like to point out
here is this button for teachers if
students click on teachers
this is where they're able to see any
teachers they're currently connected to
they can remove those teachers
and if they need to join a class one of
the easiest way for students to join a
class is to enter the class code
so this is where your students would go
if they need to input a class code to
join your class so they would enter the
class code in the space here
and click join the class
once they do that your name will appear
in the right hand side as a teacher
so if you're ever concerned that the
student is not connected to your class
properly
have them go to this tab
and have them check to make sure that
you are in fact connected as a teacher
one last thing on this student learner
home
is this profile
this shows students
what they've done on khan academy so it
shows things like how many days have
they completed work on khan academy
if they've worked on any computer
programming projects they find them here
how many energy points have they earned
and how many badges have they earned so
all of these kind of gamification pieces
and tracking pieces can be found here
now i'm going to go back
to this course mastery on my learner
home
and this here is a course mastery goal
that's given by my teacher
and so if you've assigned a course
mastery goal to your students this is
what they see when they log in
they'll see in this case that we've
assigned an algebra 1 goal to this
student
it shows the course name
when the goal is due
and how much progress they've made on
the overall course
by clicking on this
it takes me directly to the course page
so i've now gone from the learner home
to the algebra one course
now some students will navigate to
courses on their own
by clicking this courses button in the
top left
this shows you all the courses that are
available across khan academy
however if you've assigned a course
mastery goal we do recommend that
students log in
land on their learner home
and then click on that bar to take them
directly to the course of study
recommended for them
from this page you'll be able to see all
the units
lessons
and even a course challenge
that assesses skills across the entire
course
for this particular course
on the left hand side
you'll see student progress
so this is overall progress in the
course
and then each of these bars align to a
unit
and you'll see that the student in this
case has made quite a bit of progress in
algebra foundations about 93 of that
unit is completed
whereas the one right below it solving
equations and inequalities is 64
mastered
from here by clicking on a unit or a
lesson students will jump into the
lesson
or unit in which they want to work
in this case they'll be able to see each
of the lessons within the unit
and the skills that are contained within
that unit
by hovering over any of these individual
skills
they'll see a sample of what that skill
looks like we know that evaluating
expressions with one variable doesn't
always make a lot of sense to students
but if they can see a sample problem
then they have a better understanding of
what they're asked to be working on
along with this you'll see that each of
these little figures has bars filled in
these are indicators of the mastery
level of that skill
so the khan academy mastery system has
various skill levels
for students each skill can be placed at
a different level
so if they have not attempted the skill
yet they'll be placed at no level and
all the bars will be grayed out
if they've attempted the skill but
they've earned less than 70 while
practicing that skill they'll be marked
as attempted but again none of the bars
are filled in
if they earn more than 70 correct when
practicing a skill
in isolation on an exercise or correctly
answer a question related to that skill
on a quiz or test they'll get moved up
to familiar
if they get 100 of the correct questions
correct when practicing the skill in
isolation on an exercise they'll be
moved up to familiar and you'll see two
of these bars filled in order to get to
mastered
they need to show that they are
competent in that skill in two different
scenarios they either need to complete
the exercise and get 100
and then demonstrate understanding of
that skill in a test or a
course challenge
so that it shows that they are
proficient in that skill in both
isolation and in mixed review or they
have to answer that question correctly
twice on two separate unit tests or
twice on the course challenge and if
students are confused at any time just
like i just did they can click on this
question mark
and
and look at skill summary and this
appears in every unit on khan academy to
understand how they need to uh what they
need to do in order to move up or down
levels
now on this unit page you can see each
of these lessons
and in general you'll see that on the
left hand side are opportunities for
students to learn or acquire new skills
where on the right hand side are
practice opportunities for students to
demonstrate their understanding of that
skill
so on the left hand side students will
find videos and articles related to the
skill they're asked to practice on the
right
as you move down the unit page you'll
see a quiz a quiz assesses all the
skills in the preceding lesson
and at the bottom of the unit
you'll see a unit test which assesses
all the skills across the unit
as you can see in this unit
i've completed much of the content but
you'll see that here where it says
recommended based on quiz 2
i have a little star
and this is recommending that i review
this concept and then try this skill
again and students will receive
individualized recommendation as they
make progress through the content
and so that while all of your students
or your children may be working on the
course independently as they make
progress on certain skills while maybe
attempting and struggling on others
the program will recommend to them
specific activities in which to engage
to make more progress
all right so let's take a look here if i
were to jump into one of these exercises
so if i were to look at this particular
exercise on evaluating expressions with
one variable
i'll open up into this exercise window
that says ready to practice
in this case i see seven questions and
it should take me about seven to eleven
minutes
and then i click let's go
i will now receive seven questions that
are all on the same topic
and once the student inputs an answer
you'll see that they get immediate
feedback in this case right i've input
the incorrect answer and it encourages
me to try again
get help or skip for now
and this gives me an opportunity to show
you two ways students can get help while
they're working independently
beneath every question
is a question here that says stop in
this case by clicking on the blue link
that says watch a video or get a hint
the student receives videos
that are specifically related to the
skill they are attempting
or if they're really stuck they click
get a hint
and it will walk them through this
particular problem step by step
with the final hint being the correct
answer to the question
one thing to note is that if students
watch the videos and then come back and
attempt the question they can still
receive full credit if they use the hint
the question will get marked incorrect
because the final step in the hints is
the actual answer to the question
again here i go with some instant
feedback to keep up my persistence
if i go back to the main page for this
course you'll see at the top here i have
a banner that says mastery challenge
along with the regular assessments built
into the course
every student will receive mastery
challenges after they've become familiar
in at least three skills
and so this mastery challenge will
highlight three skills the student has
already practiced and these are skills
specific to that student's performance
and when they do this they're able to
level up or move to mastered in that
skill if they are successful what's
important about this is that mastery
challenges are personalized space
repetition of skills and we know that
spiraling skills helps reduce learning
loss and improve knowledge retention and
so we strongly encourage students to
engage in mastery challenges once they
become available
master challenges will refresh for
students every 12 hours
now i'm going to jump back to our
learner home for a minute
and so this is great if i'm working on
course mastery but we know many students
are using assignments as well and so
again for that same class below course
mastery i see assignments
by clicking on assignments i can see all
the current assignments my teacher has
given
in this case i have a couple of videos
indicated by these triangles and a
couple of exercises for each assignment
i can see the name the class for which
it's due the due date and time and the
current status
if i haven't attempted this activity yet
it'll appear as a start button
if i have it'll show me this current
best score and in this case because i
haven't reached 100 it's encouraging me
to try again
if the assignment is a video
or an article instead of showing me the
try again button it'll show me either
completed or incompleted so if i haven't
started yet i could click start and
watch this video and once i've finished
it it'll show as completed
now these are all my current assignments
and they're ordered for students with
the most proximal or soonest due date so
in this case you can see this assignment
is due on monday whereas this isn't due
till wednesday and so students know by
clicking at the thing at the top that
they're doing the assignment that is due
next
and if they ever want to go back to look
at past assignments they can click the
tab for past on the top
and see all of their past assignments
and again here you'll see completed
videos exercises and in this case
something i haven't completed that is
now late
if i go back to active
these are my current assignments again
and here's the name by clicking on the
name of the assignment or the start
button
i'm taken directly to that activity so
instead of having to navigate through
the entire course
it takes me directly to the assignment
that my teacher has given me and jumps
into that exercise and just like with
course mastery it's same exercises so
i'll jump into the activity and receive
the same personalized support
and
instant feedback
last thing i want to go over before we
open this up to questions
is that from this student or this
learner home
on the left hand side under my account
is a tab for progress and this is very
similar to what parents and teachers can
see
by clicking on progress i can see my
progress as a student and i can alter
the time window what type of content i'm
looking at and which type of activities
from here i can see my time spent and
it's broken into two sections here my 14
minutes indicate the amount of time i've
spent on exercises this is the amount of
time students have spent actively
engaged with questions and 45 minutes of
total learning time which means this is
the total amount of time i've spent
learning on khan academy this doesn't
include things like time students spend
changing their avatars or navigating
around the site this is time they spend
engaged with any sort of assessment
exercise videos articles anything that
is active learning
then below this each of the activities
this student has engaged with it shows
me what the activity was
when did i engage with it
my current mastery level
whether that was up or down in terms of
mastery levels
the total number of questions i answered
correctly out of the total number of
problems in that exercise or quiz
and then the time spent on that
particular activity
in some cases you'll even see a little
bar that says multiple skill changes in
that case it means that multiple skills
were assessed and the student had
changes in levels across multiple scales
in that situation by students clicking
on that they'll be able to see the same
type of levels and changes across all
the skills that they used in that
exercise
now we've gone through a lot fairly
quickly
and when in doubt if anything seems
unfamiliar to students or they're ever
concerned they can always go to the help
center and so here by clicking on the
navigation button
again students can jump back to their
learner home alter their settings or in
this case get help
so the last thing we want to call out is
that if students are ever in need of
help by clicking on their own name and
selecting help they'll be directly taken
to the khan academy help center
and here they can look at frequently
asked questions or report a problem so
if they're having trouble with their
account or finding things they can
always receive help from our help center
here
now i'm going to stop here and we're
going to open it up to
we're going to open it back up to
questions
all right so first of all megan thank
you so much this is an awesome tour de
force of the student experience so
thanks for laying it out so clearly
um we've got a ton of questions i'm
going to try to sort of go to the ones
that i'm saying over and over again to
really make sure that we hit home um
this is a question from yana but it was
certainly asked by a number of other
teachers as well
which is khan has so much rich content
but a lot of it is in the text format
that can be tough for students who are
struggling with reading ability
is there any way for students to engage
with this
and have those questions read aloud as
opposed to being forced to read them
themselves
yeah i think that's a question we do
receive a lot especially from
our teachers or younger students or
teachers who are teach english language
learners and so we do not offer an in
progress in product text to speech
option and i know we hear a lot of that
a couple of recommendations though for
those students that may be having um
trouble that may have additional needs
and things like that we are enabled for
screen readers so if the case is for
students with particular needs that have
you know learning uh challenges where
they might need that screen reader we
are adapted for that and then i will
highlight for our younger learners our
khan academy kids app which is designed
for learners two through seven
um recently released a teacher um tool
set where teachers can assign things and
that does have a text to speech option
and so if you have younger learners that
release on the teacher tools just came
this week it's super exciting so if you
have younger learners i kind of
encourage you to take a look at that
um but we do hear that and it's great
feedback that we'd love to have
cool and that's perfect because we had a
number of uh early elementary and
preschool teachers who are saying hey
con kid seems great but it's not really
teacher friendly and now it is this is
brand new information that we just
linked to in the chat section yeah brand
new the features just became live in the
app store in the last 48 hours and so
teachers can now go into khan academy
kids it's really exciting and they can
see what students are doing they can
connect what they're doing at home and
in school and make assignments at the
within the app and so uh definitely
check that out and please give us
feedback because we're learning and
growing on that cool and even if you
have your own kids running around at
home in that age range feel free to use
the teacher tools to make sure that
they're getting assigned the right
content
yes absolutely
megan and i are both in that same boat
so we're definitely
um question from jan this is the
question i've been getting not just in
the webinar but in my email over the
last several weeks is my students are
saying hey i've been watching these
videos but then the teacher is not
seeing them getting checked off in that
teacher dashboard on the back end
what could be causing that disconnect
between what the student says is
happening what the teacher is seeing
a couple of things so
number one students only get credit for
watching a video if they watch at least
90 of the video and they watch it no
faster than two times regular speed so
if students are putting it on fast
forward or you know students are only
watching half the video they're not
going to get credit for that they have
to actually watch the video
and then the other thing is if students
just put the video on and forget about
it khan academy won't give them credit
if it times out so if they just left it
on and forgot about it or left it on and
then went to do something in the other
room which not that our students would
ever do that but we we do see that
happen and so they have to make sure
that they are engaged with that and not
just ignoring it so that's one set of
things that can happen the other piece
that we strongly encourage is that a lot
of students have
both a personal and a school account and
it is most likely the school account is
the one attached to the teacher so i
would go back and verify with your
student that they are logged into the
account that's attached to your class
and so they can check in on that learner
home whether or not it's their personal
or if it's their school account just by
looking at the left-hand column and
seeing if their classes are there or
checking that teachers tab so i would
double check that they are logged into
the class and i will double check that
they are watching the video actively and
it's entirely
cool great advice and then um going back
to the very beginning maybe this is the
last question we have time for
is
you know we've been talking a lot in the
last several weeks about how do you
motivate and engage students it's hard
enough even when they're in your
classroom and now when you're teaching
them from afar it's even more difficult
so casey and brie asked respectively
what were those energy points that you
referenced at the beginning and how do
students earn badges
you bet really great question so khan
academy has some really great
gamification features built into it when
students engage with any activity even
if they're getting questions incorrect
they aren't energy points because we
really want to recognize that effort and
that persistence and so
the more successful the more repetitive
they become and those good behaviors the
more energy points they earn
and those energy points allow them to do
things like upgrade that avatar that we
saw on the top left of the learner home
and the badges come from you know
certain behaviors earning certain
amounts of energy points answering you
know 10 or 15 questions on the same
topic correctly in a row or watching you
know 15 minutes of video on a singular
topic showing that they're trying to
really understand concepts
or completing challenges so if they
complete certain challenges within the
product and so those badges and energy
points are deeply connected and are
meant to engage and gamify a little bit
to keep students motivated while they're
learning
very cool and then finally i know we
have to go in a second but for those who
want to have their questions answered
even beyond the context of this webinar
what other resources are out there so
they can get the support they need when
they need it
a couple of things to recommend
from a teacher perspective we have a
great set of teacher resources right on
our khan academy site and so when you
log in as a teacher you'll see three
tabs on the top and one of them is
resources so check that out for sure
we have a keep learning microsite
specifically designed to support remote
teaching and learning right now and so i
would check that out there's all sorts
of great stuff for students for parents
for teachers everything from daily
schedules to motivation tips and so i
would start with with those two um and
then if you have other questions or
concerns definitely contact our help
center they are really incredible and
even during this really high demand time
for khan academy they're they're usually
good about getting back to you all in a
matter of hours because it's really
important that we know that our users
even especially in a time of high need
we're here for you and whatever
questions you may have cool well i've
included those links so everyone can
feel free to click into those um that
being said
you will get a recording of this webinar
so if you want to go back and look at
any particular part of of what megan
shared you can do that at your own pace
and you can also share that with fellow
educators and even parents if you want
to help them sort of get up to speed
with this experience anything else you'd
recommend there megan
one other thing um i went through this i
know pretty quickly in a live demo so
i've included a handout with this
webinar as well which is just a set of
slides that walk through the screens we
went through today with a little bit of
text so if you'd like a little bit more
time to digest everything we went
through that's available there for you
as well
cool well on behalf of megan the whole
khan academy team we want to thank you
all for making time out of your busy
afternoon to join us and we wish you
well in this really difficult endeavor
that we're all tackling right now any
final words of wisdom megan
um just remember that anything you're
doing right now is really incredible and
that we are all doing the best we can
and we are here to support you and stay
safe
great we wish you tremendous success
bye all